back in 1974 43% of Americans said that
President Richard Nixon should be
impeached this was from a Harris Paul
done in March of 1974 right now 42
percent of Americans believe that Donald
Trump should be impeached according to a
new SSRS poll and four people saying
that lots of people always want the
president impeached that's sort of true
but not to this degree for example at
the height of the Bill Clinton scandal
only 29% of Americans wanted Clinton
impeached and as you might know Nixon
eventually resigned in August of 1974
just five months after that 43% number
was hit but there's a key difference
between when Nixon resigned and what is
going on with Donald Trump which is that
Nixon ultimately resigned not so much
because 43 percent of Americans wanted
him impeached but because Republicans
his own party had lost faith in him when
we look at what's going on today
Republicans mostly still love Trump so I
don't believe that we can expect that to
end the exact same way there's another
key difference right now which is that
Richard Nixon didn't have Fox News they
didn't have the 24/7 propaganda machine
of right-wing media supporting the Nixon
administration and even if at any given
time only 1% or so of the United States
population is watching any particular
show on Fox News Fox News does have a
sort of right-wing agenda setting
ability and that is a catalyst for
really effective talking points in
defense of Trump that end up being used
by people who don't even necessarily get
them from Fox News one other difference
is that Donald Trump is still polling
approval wise in the high 30s which is
sort of the same point as saying
Republicans still support the guy and
then one other difference today compared
to 1974 with Nixon is that the electoral
map is way different today than it was
during the 1970s and so as a result I've
said this before this isn't new
impeachment shouldn't be a policy item
for Democrats going into the November
elections the midterms and mostly it
isn't because you can't run on
impeaching the president since it
depends on so many things
and it's not policy especially when the
replacement is Mike Pence if Democrats
run on we will impeach the president
when we get elected and take over the
House and Senate in 2018
in practical terms you're running on
making Mike Pence President of the
United States it also simply can't
happen if Democrats don't take over the
House and Senate especially when even
that can be sort of a losing battle
unless Republicans changed their mind
Nixon would have held on and on and on
if Republicans had stayed with them you
can't win a fight against people without
moral and ethical standards meaning that
this is merely a practical matter
Republicans stay with Trump you're not
going to see impeachment or resignations
so Democrats need a real platform for
2018 and we're about four months away
and it needs to be developed right now
because the one target needs to be for
Democrats to take over the House and
Senate in November if Democrats can take
over the House and Senate you
potentially get net neutrality back
which is a massive meta issue for the
propaganda war you neuter the Trump
agenda because if you take over the
House and Senate you relegate Donald
Trump to the executive orders that he
denounced under Barack Obama and given
Trump's authoritarian tendencies if it
starts to look really bad for
Republicans in the House and Senate as
we get closer to November I would start
to wonder are we going to see
authoritarian type moves from Trump and
by that I mean preemptively arguing that
the election is invalid some kind of
terrorist attack to fire up his base
firing Robert Muller to create chaos and
maybe try to swing things back towards
Republicans in an act of desperation I
don't know and I normally say no way to
the mere possibility of these things
happening but we've gotten pretty far
off course during the last two years of
Trump so I would be very concerned
number one if Democrats don't get a real
platform together for the midterms I I
would almost completely write off the
possibility of taking over the House and
Senate I hope that doesn't happen but if
it starts to look like Democrats might
actually have some success there
what does the Trump administration and
Trump's lackeys what do they do to try
to retain control beyond January of 2019
when the new House and Senate would be
sworn in